at first glance it looks a bit like the
tides out
revealing a muddy shoreline but this is
not silt
and it's not meant to be here
marine mucilage also known as cesnot
has blanketed this turkish coastline now
for days
seen here under the water clinging to
rocks and seaweed
you can understand the problem it's
causing to see life
it's alarming both for fishermen and for
local people
the root cause of
this the season is really
we need to limit the amount of uh
anthropogenic derived nutrients that are
entering the sea
we need to stop or or slow down
climate change the warming because one
way or another
it's going to affect our seas the slimy
layer is formed when algae is
overloaded with nutrients it's a natural
process but one that has got completely
out of control campaigners have blamed
global warming
and have called on president erdogan's
government to step in
just like we cleaned golden horn which
was a greater trouble
hopefully we will save our seas from the
trouble of mutilage
my fear is if this expands to the black
sea and comes to marmara
from there the trouble will be enormous
we need to take the step without delay
work has begun to try and remove the
sludge but this
is a massive problem for the city to
tackle and one
so far for which there doesn't seem to
be an obvious solution
harriet hadfield sky news